[Music]
welcome to the famous and infamous
las colinas resort
acapulco in 1980 was the best place to
be everyone from hollywood was there and
the parties were insane
the aesthetic was really unique and
wonderful you guys know the word
bodacious the hotel is a complete
extension of acapulco we needed
something with a lot of personality that
screams and shouts mexico in every shot
here we are in the lobby most of what
you're going to see wasn't here the
ladies work was created inspired by
gladys word from acapulco those arches
weren't there of course the color wasn't
here when i got here it was kind of like
a beigey brown color and within a day
they had painted the entire hotel pink
it definitely brought it more to life it
just gave it a like a positive energy we
went a little crazy and we said like why
not it's very flashy it's very vibrant
very 80s
i hope coming to visit las paulinas will
always be
in fashion
see what i did there yes i'd want to go
back to the 80s are you crazy who
wouldn't want to go back to the 80s i
love the 80s i love the fashion that
happened in that time for example
i like the fun about the 80s when you're
wearing 80s clothes it just makes you
feel i don't know more badass it's a
collaboration with wardrobe with hair
and makeup we have an amazing team
all the art all the lamps and every
detail that you can see was designed
and custom made for the show
even though it's a comedy even though
it's so bold and so colorful it's a very
authentic and fun story the vibe the
food the colors the people this is a
real mexico acapulco is a real mexico
you